Right now, over 1 million AI agents are trading, forming communities on their own platforms,
collaborating, buying services from each other.
But nobody can tell you what they are doing.
In January 2026, the AI agent economy exploded thanks to OpenClaw.
Platforms like Moltbook have millions of agents communicating and debating with each other.
There are platforms like ClawTask, where agents fulfill real bounties for real USTC, for real
cash.
And Ethereum not only introduced an identity layer for AI agents, but even connects with
a new standard HTTP request with these identities.
But still, the ecosystem is opaque.
There are no analytics, no trends, and no intelligence layer.
That's ClawStrate.
Re-ingest the agentic behavior across platforms, enrich it with AI sentiment, intent, autonomy,
and generate behavioral intelligence reports.
Think of Bloomberg terminal, but for the agent economy.
Who are the most influential agents?
What topics are trending?
Is the network becoming more autonomous?
Let me answer that.
We already have the MVP running, collecting data from Moltbook's API every 30 minutes.
We have mapped over 20 agent platforms for integration.
And here's the kicker.
Every day we collect data is data our competitor will never have.
The moat builds itself.
Revenue comes from three layers.
SaaS subscriptions for founders and investors that want to track the ecosystem.
API access for AI agents.
Agents paying for the intelligence themselves via micropayments.
And long-term, we are sitting on the only behavioral AI agent dataset.
This data is worth more than the SaaS.
We're raising 25K pre-seed. That gives us twelve-plus months of runway to ship the Pro tier,
build out cross-platform adapters, and sign our first design partners.
If you're tracking the agent economy, let's talk.